good evening and thanks for joining us
tonight at 11 o'clock I'm Sasha Loftis
new tonight a story you'll only see on 8
news now a family searching for a
missing cross at the memorial site of
their son who died 12 years ago Madison
Kimbrough spoke with the family who says
they don't understand who could do this
she joins us live near Craig and
Cimarron with more Madison
is here where Michael wyan's Cross was
placed you can take a look and see it
but all you can see obviously are just
rocks left and his family speaking to me
hoping that someone out there knows what
happened to it
to live every day without him here it's
just unreal and unhar you know and then
just to come here and see that the cross
has gone gone
it's just that makes it even brings
everything back to the surface we see
them all across the valley memorials set
up for lost loved ones Debbie wyand and
husband Mike lost their son Michael in a
motorcycle accident 12 years ago
and for years have had a memorial cross
set up in his honor at the crash site
until a couple weeks ago when they
noticed it was gone we've had this cross
in in memory of our son Michael
for since 2011.
and to pass by it and see that it's gone
we just wanted to reach out the Wayans
wondering if the city took it down or
maybe the neighborhood HOA but both have
confirmed that it wasn't them we were
grasping for straws to see if there was
any cameras or security footage and
there was really nothing it was
Michael's wife who told them his cross
was missing after driving by one day
Michael who would have been 33 now is
described by his family as an outgoing
person who loved to explore the outdoors
he loved rock climbing he pretty much
lived at Red Rock but now with his cross
gone his family searching for answers
and having to relive a moment in time
that changed their lives forever we
don't really like to be here because it
reminds us of the accident it just
brings up a lot of sadness again
as for a replacement the wines have
already ordered another one but hope the
original will be found and returned to
them soon reporting here in the
Northwest Valley Madison Kimbrough 8
News Now